françois rang des moins chères qui
m'aimait bien sûr de noël chuté à vos
ordres que puis-je faire pour vous eh
bien à déplacer une armoire d'accord ah
oui mais une armoire à glace superbe
très lourde bon bah écoutez d'accord ou
excusez moi le téléphone retentit pardon
à l'eau ah c'est toi julie comment vas
tu tu vas pas bien qu'est ce que tu as
tu es malade allons bon mais ce matin en
se levant de ton lit tu es tombé que tu
t'es foulé la cheville en or que c'est
que cette histoire non mais je n'ai
occident je ris parce que je croyais que
tu me racontait une histoire c'est vrai
c'est sérieux coup de lime il faut être
raisonnable fait tranquille lui de venir
s'installer à la maison je vais lui
préparer des bonnes plantes qui volent
tout à fait là stage est d'accord julie
mademoiselle fut-elle se propose de
l'héberger pendant quelques jours
jusqu'à ce que tu as cheville soit
réparée l'accès julie tu te prépares et
nous passons de prendre dans une heure
alors à tout de suite pour ce compris
les manuels futé julie est très mal elle
souffre beaucoup mais je suis très
content qu'elle soit chez vous elle sera
entre de bonnes mains et ainsi je
pourrai lui rendre visite plus je vais
de ce pas lui préparer une décoction
deux résultats blancs céréales huiles de
tournesol au kivu lui fera bien je suis
tout de suite on se retrouve à la mise
autant tu entends tu que tu as entendu
romain voulait assainir c'est un
scandale ils prennent des décisions sans
nous demander notre avis on a même plus
confiance en nous et puis et puis c'est
incroyable parce que qui dit même pas
compte que nous aussi on est inquiet a
commis des fonctions de président au
tournant
ces projets libres et malheureux chez
mademoiselle [ __ ] ce sera sans arrêt
mon petit poussin jaune par si mon petit
aux bleus quelle horreur
et puis non à la presse que je suis
persuadé qu'on ne nous autorisera même
pas à les avoir tu crois surtout non
pourquoi moi surtout pour enfin ce toi
parce que tu es nouveau dans l'île tu as
un visiteur on ne va pas autorisées se
colore on autorise à moi même puis
d'avoir tu pars renfort coûte casimir tu
exagères
hippolyte à j'estime qu'on l'honore des
casimir eu sept ans je pense est vrai
j'oubliais
hippolyte harris il faut prendre une
grande décision fono là nous allons
enlever julie quoi
frémir quand tu plaisantes non pas du
tout
mais comment va-t-on faire bon bah c'est
très simple nous allons chez elle nous
naviguons pour gérer un papa lui faire
mal tu la prend sur ton dos oui bon
point moi je prends sa petite valise à
la maison tu crois vraiment casimir bien
sûr
que ça va se passer sans problème
facilement confiance j'aimerais bien les
léonards pour qu'ils préparent tous et
nous y allons non mais ça ne va quand
même pas se passer comme ça non ça
ne
sera pas l'eau d'où ce que nous faisons
est pour toi bien
on a tous les sens
lisez son téléphone comme un petit
message en sorte comme c'est prévisible
sans explication
j'attends ça
vous êtes conscient c'est pourtant là
haut tu vois mais pas très contente
on n'aurait pas dû faire une chose
pareille attends je vais arroser ça
ma très chère julie
silence écoute moi nous avons pensé
enfin bon bref nous t'avons rang levée
parce que tu es malade
françois et mademoiselle futin avait
décidé de s'occuper de toi et nous avons
pensé que tu saurais beaucoup mieux chez
moi que dans la maison de mademoiselle
fut très beau et inité soigneront très
bien nous n'avons besoin de personne
vous ayez tu t on n'a pas eu le temps
d'expliquer parce que on a voulu éviter
françois alors on est parti très vite
c'est mademoiselle futile nous n'aurions
même pas pu aller te voir et tu nous
aurait manqué d'état provisions et des
tables pour te distraire et voilà c'est
quelquefois
havas alors vouliez me regarde et vous
occupez moi
c'est tout récemment que ça c'est
vraiment gentil alors on va je suis
touché entre s'allier à les toucher
enfin quand même vous auriez pu vous y
prendre autrement mais c'était
impossible
si bien que françois n'a aucune
confiance en nous et oui s'il s'arrête
que tu te trouves là il serait malade
inquiétudes et puis tu sais bien que
mademoiselle futé qui avec françois
d'ailleurs fait est très très très
nerveuse
donne moi ton pied que je rencontre sont
grandes a signé tous
oui
[Musique]
this way léonard pour toi
et moi mac il est vrai moi vite mais
casillas avait la
tirait la bobinette et la cheville est
cher aura
montré patte blanche
dépêche-toi globale ou en chimie il m'a
traité de gros balourd mais en plus un
pack n'est pas blanc l'on fasse du bien
hippolyte ces mois quasiment 2 est
quasiment à temps
mais amicale expédition rasé que je n'y
arriverai jamais raconte moi j'ai vu
françois et mademoiselle foutaise ne
comprennent rien il cherche julie
partout et ils sont inquiets j'espère
ils sont morts d'inquiétude à l'epo et
que leur as tu dis pas bien pour les
rassurer j'ai dû leur dire la stricte
vérité trop
ils vont chercher je ne pense jamais
nous mais ne vous en faites pas tout va
bien se passer
ma maison est devenue une forteresse
imprenable
nous sommes nombreux forts et armés et
puis nous avons des provisions pour au
moins trois heures
bakassi n'écoute ce pas très gentil vous
pourriez peut-être veut prêter à eux et
puis je reviendrai après non
parce que en plus après ils te garderont
voilà te défendrons jusqu'à l'aube voilà
pourquoi les organisons nous enfin quoi
il en lit tu vas te coucher là ici voilà
moi ici
et puis on arrive bientôt à bout de la
garde
pourquoi moi pourquoi toi parce que tu
es le plus intelligent comment lui mais
tu m'as dit hier que c'était moi le
témoin en voyons et puis tu as aussi
leflux courageux
ou d'un casque
dormez tranquilles champagne
on se couche la
moins que des couvertures
je lis je lis tu es là
julie où que vous soyez répondez-nous
julie enfin je lis que se passe-t-il
elle ne répond pas ils ont peut-être
enfermé dans le tunnel mon studio le
pauvre julie au casino monte trop
délaissé les gros oiseaux
sont nous qui vous feront d'humains quel
langage face à vous avez entendu
très commentée des mots sont pas
historiques moi qui croyait avoir
affaire à des quasi oui si notre casino
ouvre immédiatement soirée largement
view ne peux vous donner sa chance
jamais las dos des paysans
au fassois
rien je suis là
bonjour mes amis maires mais rassurez
vous je suis je suis reparti était pas
au
julien je n'avais rien à cacher je vous
en fais bien mon nom mais pourquoi
voulez-vous que léonard casimiri police
me fasse du mal il voulait simplement se
soigner mais julie mais mes nouveaux
livres exactement faire la même chose
oui seulement vous avez vecsey quasi
bien il polit temps on les leur
demandant pas le racing s'est fait un
joli
que tu marches
mais je n'ai plus mal dit oh il faut
lutter au phare et casimir sont des
infirmiers parfait on va en fait donc
six mois julie mais des infirmiers qui
veulent enlever leurs malades
oublions tout son brio tout ça le
principal est que j'ai une histoire du
jury mais
quand je pense que c'est sommerau
signalant qu'ils ont fait c'est
mieux contacter les gens
criaient
[Musique]